a leader of leaders the most
extraordinary woman of our times she
will always be a winner and I'll always
be with her
my friend Hillary Rodham Clinton
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all very very much
you know before I I begin I want to say
a few words about the news this morning
of suspicious packages being sent to
various public figures and a news
organization many of you and others
across our country have asked after me
and my family and I'm very grateful for
that we are fine thanks to the men and
women of the Secret Service who
intercepted the package addressed to us
long before it made its way to our home
every day we are grateful for their
service and commitment and obviously
never never more than today but it is a
troubling time isn't it and it's a time
of deep divisions and we have to do
everything we can to bring our country
together we also have to elect
candidates who will try to do the same
who will set goals that will lift up
every single Floridian and American who
will look into the future to understand
what are the challenges we have to meet
today so that our children and our
grandchildren have the quality of life
and the opportunities that we hope for
them usually when people ask me how am i
doing which happens quite often
I say well as a person I'm great as an
American I'm worried and it's actually
for the same reasons part apparently why
I am so great is because with no offense
to anyone I have the most fabulous
grandchildren in the entire world
but because I do now have these little
precious people I worry about the
direction of our country I worry about
what kind of world will be waiting for
them
when they're teenagers and young adults
and beyond so it's a special pleasure
for me to be here to support the
candidates that you have running in
Florida I had the great opportunity
yesterday to spend time with Andrew
Gilliam and RJ and with Kris and Kristyn
King and I can tell you you will be in
very good hands
when Andrew Illinois was elected
I also said that I have the rare
experience of being both a candidate and
a spouse and being a spouse is a lot
harder so I'm excited that RJ and
Kristin who you just saw will be there
in Tallahassee doing everything they can
to improve the lives of the people of
this state and particularly the children
I'm also delighted to be here with
former Representative Ron Klein thank
you so much Ron and I want Mary bars e
Flores to waive her hand or stand up and
Mary thank you so much for running in
the 25th district now it's always fun
for me to be in Florida I first came to
Florida when I was ten years old driving
down here with my parents they will
never forget stopping at a little cafe
in north Florida sitting at a counter to
have some lunch and a man walked in with
a small alligator on a leash you know
how some memories just get embedded in
your head and no matter what else
happens to you they stay there that's
one of them I also remember coming here
as a teenager with some of my friends
now if you don't tell anybody I will
confess that I actually was stopped for
unlawful waterskiing but what happens in
Fort Lauderdale stays in Fort Lauderdale
but all those memories and what I've
seen in the many many times that I have
come to Florida is a state with enormous
potential to really not only prepare for
your future but to set
Stage four what America will do to
prepare for our future you know it's
quite astonishing that Florida the
Sunshine State hasn't been leading not
just the United States but the world in
clean renewable energy isn't it I mean
it's always shocking to me when I see
statistics that claim that states like
New Jersey actually have more renewable
energy than Florida go figure
but that's a lack of leadership an
unwillingness to prepare for the future
that awaits I'm also thrilled that
Florida continues to grow third most
populous state in our country but with
growth comes responsibility and how to
educate those children how to provide
for preschool how to make sure our
seniors have what they need to enjoy the
retirement that they came to be part of
here in Florida
so there are real-world daily issues
that we have to confront and that
Florida needs new leadership to enable
it to make the right decisions going
forward so I'm here to talk about
someone who understands this completely
you know Donna has been my dear friend
for many many years and in everything
she has ever done from being a cabinet
secretary who served for eight years to
a university president she has lived and
worked her heart out to improve the
lives of the people she was responsible
for helping now that's a simple concept
but hard work coupled with vision and
determination is how you get things done
and there is no better person to have in
your corner than Donna shillelagh now
that's why at this moment 13 days from
such a consequential election it is
imperative that people in this district
and across Florida vote for leaders who
will put them first
not their party not their partisanship
not their commercial interests not any
of the other matters that seem to fuel
too many people who run for and hold
office today there's a crisis facing our
country and I don't use that word
lightly there's a crisis in our
democracy a crisis in our ability to
make the tough decisions to govern
ourselves and now we've got a chance to
try to begin to reverse that it's
obviously very disturbing to me that
when you look at what has been done in
Washington over the last now you know
nearly two years it hasn't really been
aimed at helping the people of this
district or the people of Florida except
for the very very few you know time
after time we have seen decisions made
that exacerbate problems not in any way
move towards solving them and we hear a
lot about immigration well the last time
I looked the other party controlled the
White House and the Congress if they
wanted to fix immigration instead of
using it as a whipping post they could
have they could have made changes that
would have already been improving the
situation for immigrants and putting us
on a better path if they wanted to
really be fair in a tax system they
wouldn't have benefited corporations and
the wealthy to the extent that they did
and now we hear in fact they let the
secret out my friends Mitch McConnell
the other day basically said well you
know we got some budget problems well
yes I guess so self-inflicted budget
problems nevertheless budget problems
and so we're gonna have to look at
Medicare and Social Security and
Medicaid
you cannot be more cynical than that but
that's what they said and I will
guarantee you that if they are returned
to majority in the Congress that is what
they will do so the list goes on but
there's good news too and let me stress
that because I am fundamentally
optimistic I'm optimistic about our
country and our future as long as we
make the right decisions and I'm
particularly optimistic about young
people one of the most moving sights
that I have ever seen
is watching the Parkland students try to
bring us to our senses about
common-sense gun safety measures and
there are merit many other young people
individually and together who are
fighting for the changes they want to
see because they understand those
changes will affect their lives you know
every election is about the future and
fundamentally every election has
consequences and those consequences are
much more impactful on young people than
those of us who are no longer young
people who have more tomorrow's by
definition have more at stake in the
leaders that we elect and the agendas
that they pursue so this election is as
critical as any that I can remember and
think about what Donna has done her
proven track record of leadership and
what she will do and I will tell you
this if you want someone to clean up the
mess in Washington send Donna shillelagh
she knows more about healthcare than
anybody in the Congress ever has or ever
will nobody's gonna get past her about
doing away with protections for
pre-existing conditions
nobody's gonna convince her to cut a
little here and cut a little there on
Social Security and Medicare and
Medicaid in order to go after
entitlements to fix the budget no
there's an easier way
reverse the absolutely wrongheaded tax
bill that gave the rewards to the top 1%
no one will convince her that public
schools and higher education don't need
to be funded because she knows what a
difference a good teacher in the
classroom can make for a child from any
zip code and no one will convince her
that we don't need early childhood
education and preschool programs to help
every single child no matter where that
child is from to have the best shot at
learning and no one will convince her
that we need to continue to see the
carnage that we experience because of
the gun laws that the NRA has
intimidated people into supporting in
the last year's and if you believe in
comprehensive immigration reform and
protecting dreamers and keeping families
together
she's your person she has the best
ability to take a problem break it down
and figure out how to solve it then
probably anybody I've ever worked with
so when she's in Washington you'll see a
lot of her because she's gonna have to
be standing up and speaking out against
the assault on facts evidence truth and
reason that is a daily staple of what's
happening in our Capitol
but she can't do that without your help
just like Andrew Gilliam can give great
speeches and do a fantastic job in his
debate if any of you saw it right but it
won't matter if people don't turn out
and vote and if you don't do everything
you can in the next 13 days to convince
people who are not yet sure it's worth
the couple of hours it might take to
vote apparently there are some long
lines in miami-dade because so many
people want to vote but don't let that
discourage you you know take a cooler
bring a lawn chair that investment of
time will pay off over and over again
when you have leaders who are going to
pay attention to you not do the bidding
of their rich corporate donors their
ideological partisan advisors we've got
to get back to common sense American
problem solving ability we've got to
start talking and listening you know I
don't think any one person has all the
answers that's obviously not at all the
case but people working together and
listening to each other can come up with
good answers so we need to really bear
down these next 13 days thank you for
being here and generously supporting
Donna's campaign
it means the world because she's got to
get her message out there she's got to
be competitive online and on broadcast
and in papers and everywhere else people
are seeking information but whatever
you've done if you can do a little more
that would be very helpful if you've
knocked on some doors if you can do some
more that will be helpful if you've made
some calls but you can do some more I
hope you will
we can't take anybody's vote for granted
take it from me I know a little bit
about this
so I am hoping that we have a very
pleasant morning on November 7th right
[Applause]
you know in 1992 a long time ago
when we were campaigning with the Gores
all over the country it was one of the
best stories that was used to end the
speaking and it was usually delivered by
Al Gore and Al Gore would say imagine
it's election day and you got tired of
waiting for the results and you had to
get up early so you went to bed but you
were confident about how it was gonna
turn out then you woke up the next
morning and you put on the coffee and
you started to just stretch and move
into the day and then you turned on the
news and you heard that your candidate
lost in addition to the depression that
sets in people start saying well maybe I
could have done a little more maybe I
could have stretched a little further
well I'm here to tell you yes I'm
confident that each and every one of you
can and I hope that you will I for one
want to be able to look my grandchildren
in the eyes and say that when it counted
I tried my very hardest to do everything
I could to persuade people to vote for
leaders like Andrew Gilliam and Chris
King and Donna shillelagh that would
actually care about them in their
futures and would try to bring people
together not divide us
I still believe that's what we are going
to get but we won't get it by wishing
and hoping for it we will get it by hard
work so we have to get everyone out to
vote and tell everyone whatever issue
they care about it is on the ballot and
maybe Donna shillelaghs name but if you
care about guns or climate change or
Medicare Social Security Medicaid
pre-existing conditions education
whatever you care about it's all
steak so 13 days let's make sure Donna
shillelagh goes to Congress
[Applause]
[Music]